news right now Justin hey waltz in the
house I believe it's April first which
means you're an idiot I'm an idiot on
every day this is the one day i'm not an
idiot oh really this is one day I'm a
genius because it's a joke that you're
not an it has literally anything can be
true everything's reversed there is no
news today because it's April first and
anyone who actually tried to do
something serious would just be
completely ignored oh and so so every
story today has just been completely
ridiculous over-the-top then we we had a
lot of the this the things that we
expect to see like blizzard always has
really yes April full story what does it
do this year so Blizzard had several
announcement they always he do like
three or four of these one of them was
four outcasts Vengeance of the Vanguard
which is a blizzard fighting game like
Street Fighter Crying Game there's a
dirt devil character there's a huge ship
like a starcraft ship that you can use
to just go and decimate your opponents
and in the affair that sounds okay it's
it's really the screen the love that
they put into it is so awesome like
seeing all the screens and the character
I'd like they obviously put so much time
into creating this and this is the
problem with when they do this is that
whenever Blizzard do this people go yeah
that's right I'll buy the Nicole they
canna make that game and then they do
yeah the ethical pandas going to pounds
that's exactly the pandas were a joke
the pan is our an April Fool's joke and
then they built an entire expanse that
time they joked about making a MOBA
there all right and a card game Oh
Blizzard you so crazy so another one
that is much more in depth lately
announced the starcraft 2 expansion is
going to be Herald of the stars which by
itself isn't funny but it's another ALCS
and all I can you read through it and
they just do that acronym over and over
again right it's really it's a very
funny read I mean it doesn't translate
well they're just talking about it yeah
but I mean you definitely want to check
out blizzard and all the crazy stuff
that they had but one a couple things
leaked a little bit early so we saw some
stuff yesterday that Google is teaming
up with Nintendo to offer a Pokemon game
basically on your phone where you can
look at google maps and find pokemon all
over the world but you have to zoom in
really close and you have to literally
just like move very slowly and tap on
Pokemon add them to your pokedex and I
did that's real like you can do that
right there what joke is sorry go ahead
oh so the joke is that if you catch all
100
Pokemon you will be made the Pokemon
master of Google and they will fly you
out oh yes they can probably afford to
just make up a dumb position like that
and I just always have a person on staff
for that what's the scale like WIC what
is a Bulbasaur the size of like a city
block well I mean it's just you're like
super easily fine because it's just as
yes Snorlax is the size of Peru so I
mean they're they're they're big enough
for you to find when using you have to
zoom in pretty close like yep they're
about the size of a building okay you've
but the further you zoom out the harder
they are to find that and then based on
where the rat like it I think there's
one around madrid you can zoom out kind
of far and still like look at most of
Spain and still find that one but for
like San Francisco you have to zoom in
really close and go like Street by
street to find all of these these crazy
pokemon in that one there were a couple
other announcements that were not as
funny alright not as funny similar just
kind of sad its rapid fire so we had fez
to was announced okay yeah which is
probably announced probably not true
Rihanna Rihanna on again and out bungee
also has a special edition for their
game destiny coming out for just seven
million dollars they will send you to
Mars to dad is a bargain it's actually
really dark they're like we will
physically augment your body and send
you to Mars where you will die in the
vacuum of space wow wow nice bungee it's
seven mil to go to Mars I mean I think
that's actually a bargain yeah that's
okay yeah I mean it seems it that's it
that's a deal and you can also get a
really good deal on a mass effect 2
garrus body pillow garrison you know the
huge alien guy yeah you can cuddle up
with him just like hold him closely that
nigerians are one of the cuddliest
species in the galaxy and for the jagged
faces well I'm very surprisingly supple
and they don't ever come in at a suits
either it was only in pillow for my bet
it's a little bit nicer where's the hole
and the last story that we had was
actually one from us we said that dark
souls 2 is going to be introducing a
patch with an item to makings became a
little bit easier for us the this
actually Rick it's actually got me you
got it because i was on the email of
what should we be the april fools joke
at gamespot com yeah and it's lagaa me
the one that met Martin wanted to do
which was battlefields EA
I'm carrying like required battlefield 4
patch crashes in transmission I thought
was pretty good but no one's gonna fall
for that we had we had a lot of good
ideas about this one but ultimately this
was the one that seemed the most
realistic yeah that we could pitch and
didn't get some some people fall for it
in comments some people I mean some it's
April Fool's like it's hard ones on your
anything serious yeah but now people
were like I don't know if this is April
Fool's be better not do this to that
game from somewhere I like it and that's
the last April Fool the game spot is
done they're absolutely no more april
fools we've done now definitely only one
no chance sure it's all serious from
here on it yeah all right Justin yes we
let you go anyway considering you've got
absolutely no work to do apparently I'm
just going to go look at a cat videos
right